i think the problem is there's  unintended consequences like they say  the path to hell is paved with good  intentions so i'll give you an example  um in california they wanted to help the  homeless population  so they gave out um they're giving money  to homeless people people that are  homeless and that resulted in people  moving to california to be homeless wow  yeah and there's a guy on the um that  they recorded he was like being  interviewed and he literally tells them  he's like i'm a crackhead i moved from  texas to california so i could be  homeless because they pay you to be  homeless here it's great i get 600 bucks  a month to just yeah  right now  i know  we're about to be homeless  i got a home when i go back but you see  like so so again it's these people  saying oh i know what's best so i know  what's best for these people that i'm  not  and i'm i'm gonna pat myself on the back  oh look at me i'm helping the poor